t'as pas peur quand même que de faire un
peu de com on doit beaucoup dans les
journaux racontent et à villalier encore
un deux films on doit sans arrêt on va
surtout le premier jambi où c'est un
portrait de toi tu m'as pas du tout
l'impression d'avoir accordé ma vie
alors là vraiment je suis le premier à
me trouvais ça un peu ennuyeux parfois
ils leurs enfants et ben justement
l'astuce non parce que dans le portrait
vous voyez que vous voyez des vous voyez
des interviews des trucs qui sont comme
moi mais vous ne voyez pas une infamie
ma famille tout le monde dans le faux
dans le petite histoire que j'ai été
moins et gagner ça a mis en scène et
écrit également c'est c'est là où tu
vois les vraies mais c'est dans une
histoire faut pour l'autre côté c'est
beaucoup plus drôle de faire des choses
qui n'ont rien à voir avec d'aironi des
rôles que tu as joué dans le passé
sinon on aurait fait ça sur l'actrice
mars avec des rôles qu'elle a bien fait
ou mal fait il se serait dirigé par le
jeune australien
j'aurais bien aimé moi j'aime beaucoup
beaucoup s'attacher aux internautes mais
ça c'est une autre test et aida c'est
une chose avec deux personnes vraiment
vivant j'espère tata pas perdre une
odeur explosion quand même de comptes
voit beaucoup trop comme s'ils arrivent
à certains moments je t'aime tu crois
pas qu'il est aujourd'hui les stars ont
tendance à se renfermer là à ce moment
là j'aurais pas dû faire cette émission
voilà qui sont les dangers de
l'explosion sont certainement les deux
ferme la plus polie fine que vous avez
fait mon dieu on les fait sont je pense
plutôt d'avoir été plus original que ça
va mais peut-être en effet en direct à
aucune il faut dix étaient ce les
télévisions au point en neuvième pour
les journalises je touche parfois je ne
crois
non
je mets ça serait un peu vache d'avoir
utilisé les talents de l'équipe des
vignes mettre en scène qu'un consacré un
an et quelques mois de sa vue sur vous
et de pensée pas mal de sous de ne pas
venir parler de cette entreprise qui me
semble original et celui personne qui
vous parle de surexposition justement ce
qui vous [ __ ] des couvertures alors
ils sont gonflés
non mais si les tiens me taise des
médias mais non j'ai pas j'essaie d'être
direct je sais pas peut-être que cet
enduit de faire la promotion des films y
est un acteur c'est pas le moment que je
préfère parce que j'existe la famille et
quand ça s'appelle un j'aime beaucoup
défendre quand les autres attaques ça
c'est marrant je n'ai pas dire pourquoi
tu as fait quelque chose ça tienne
debout ça devrait tenir tout ça à la
limite on dort on n'aurait pas dû faire
ça je valais de leurs exposés aux
risques et choisir qui aurait pu ne pas
être là quand ce film sortait parce que
c'était très très personnel à sepa sepa
pour cette raison là que non je trouve
ces deux films l'un est plus facile à
parler parce que tu tu peux parler d'eux
les autres acteurs tu peux parler d'eux
le travail des acteurs comme mathieu
demy et joue le petit garçon comme
chalet de 15 jours comme comme un pro
première tu peux parler de leur travail
d'acteur et pas seulement que ce soit
votre famille mais c'est toujours c'est
pas très brillant pendant des filles
j'espère des tenues dans les films de
cette famille c'est très bien
très joli c'est pas très joli inhérents
donc tu es tu vas partir là vraiment on
la mairie pendant lequel sa fille c'est
vrai ça je vais partir c'est un
département c'est un département n'a
rien on à part ça j'imagine mais c'est
un départ comme quand tu es venu en
france ou à l'étranger quoi valider les
raisons valises départ est mis sur pied
ce prix car cher souchon non je vais je
vais faire un film avec deux nuls soit
de l'entente en canada chose promise
après tout il ya un an
on m'a demandé de jouer sa maîtresse
j'ai trouvé c'est chic parce que c'était
ton chez elle après ça on m'a dit tu
peux pas faire ça parce que tu es à
clermont ferrand
c'est vrai je suis en train de faire de
le tourner du bataclan après ça je
faisais des films d'agnès donc raté pour
moi d permettrait son film qui fait que
maintenant je joue sa femme qui râlent à
propos de ses 13 j avoue que la vie est
drôle donc je vais me taper une déprime
1 dans le film comme la femme les fans
désabusés de donal byrne ça va être un
plaisir truffe à brac ma valise emma et
malou dans ma valise ce faire trois
films en anglais je vais je vais faire
un tour prend l'air pour un peu je vois
ce qui se passe quel bilan que tu tires
de
du virage que tu as pris il ya quelques
années en commençant à jouer du marivaux
de ses coûts
ouais je t'ai satisfait finalement ça
parce que des fois il y en a c'est ça
c'est ça qui est bien marché battait
jamais contente j'ai comprendre parce
qu'avant on faisait des comédies td pas
contente après tu as fait des trucs un
peu tragique c'est sérieux c'est quand
on me connaissant pas croyab devrait
faire les aider oui mais non des
cacahuètes dans l'oeil moi j'aime bien
ça enfin quand ces gens-là quand ces
gens-là tour appelé été très flatté je
ne sais pas quand j'allais de demander
de faire ce genre de film et était
contente qu'on te le demande depuis
maintenant cinq ans après t'as pas l'air
non plus très satisfaite de ce que je
trouve que j'ai énormément de tours de
retourner les originales ces dernières
années je veux dire godard toutes
origines à brive est carrément varda
superlatif il s'est passé des choses que
je ne m'y attendais pas c'est pour ça
que c'est difficile d'arrêter parce que
les choses sont sans inattendue et puis
le bataclan avec des chansons de serge
où c'était c'était quelque chose que à
laquelle je n'aurais pas pensé mais
quand j'ai commencé dans le théâtre avec
chéreau et piccoli j'ai quand même
compris que j'étais donner vos mains je
suis pas si vieux que ça j'ai su que
quand je ne descendrai j'étais dans une
sorte de protection formidable j'ai fait
des gens qu'ils ont fait de la sorte que
j'ai l'air bien voilà voilà
et on accentue pourraient avoir moins
d'accent s'est formellement pas très
grave j'en fais pas un peu tu ne te
rajoute pas un peu de l'accent anglais
t'as pas remarqué misère j'ai mal à la
gorge devait faire ah bah écoute
franchement et coude à coude de première
version de je t'aime moi non plus je
roulais pas nerfs maintenant je suis
presque management écoute franchement
c'est toi que je t'aime de concret mais
peinera marque à jamais perçu c'est une
superwoman monter une famille un travail
tout à la fois l'ancien super là-dedans
[Musique]
d'avoir des enfants ont pu rentrer chez
soit et mais je les peluches mais
j'espère je tenais pas marre d'être une
superbe a tout à fait les choses
mais je suis pas un super vous mènera
tout comme tout le monde on est inséré
de ratage après ça on est très large
pendant des années ou pendant le moment
et tout d'un coup en un spasme de
courage
c'était pas le courage tout le long
c'est l'espace mme cengic les 60 ans ce
qui est bien chez toi c'est qu'il a
toujours peur de faire pas bien ça c'est
tout le monde a peur de pas faire ouais
parce que je suis aujourd'hui
non mais si vous avez absolument de
conviction quand vous à qu'on ait
confiance en vous
le poids de la responsabilité de cette
chose donnée à vous et remarquablement
lourde
j'ai toujours un petit peu peur de
ressembler à mes report de l'école tu
sais il on disait il disait est pas doué
mais j'en doute
les corrections de ne rien rater de
l'inaptitude abonnez vous mettez un
pouce bleus